[Music]
the riddler is one of the most famous
villains in all of comic book history
second perhaps only to the joker since
first appearing in an october 1948 issue
of detective comics edward enigma has
continuously proven to be one of
batman's most challenging foes known for
his love of crime drama and of course
one singularly puzzling punctuation mark
the riddler has appeared in nearly as
many mediums as the batman himself in
addition to his long history in the
comic books the riddler has also made a
number of memorable appearances in
animated form most animated riddler fans
are likely familiar with john glover's
iteration of the character from 1992's
batman the animated series but glover's
animated version of the character is
actually only one of many the first
animated riddler appeared in a 1968 cbs
tv series titled the batman superman
hour in his first animated incarnation
the famous villain is voiced by actor
ted knight and since the riddler's debut
in animation he has been voiced by no
less than 14 different actors of course
most people are probably more familiar
with the various live-action adaptations
of the character in the 1960s nigma was
played by two actors the adams family
star john astin played the character in
the second season of adam west's batman
tv series however the actor who arguably
made the character famous was frank
gorshin whose portrayal of the character
in seasons 1 and 3 of the show is still
considered one of the best versions of
the character ever gorham's riddler was
so beloved by audiences and critics that
the actor was nominated for an emmy a
first for the batman franchise gorshin
would also go on to reprise his role as
the riddler in the 1966 film of the same
name and in the years since the
riddler's fame has only grown many
millennials probably first came to know
the character as a result of jim
carrey's role in 1995's batman forever
though that film isn't beloved by many
carrie's campy performance is often
noted as a highlight of the movie
now
that's impressive
modern tv audiences may be more familiar
with corey michael smith's take on
enigma from the 2014 fox series gotham
matt reeves the batman is also set to
tackle a new incarnation of the infamous
character according to a recent
interview with reeves this version of
the riddler is actually named edward
nashton and is loosely based on the
zodiac killer so who is the next actor
set to bring him to life emmy
award-nominated actor paul dano will
portray the infamous villain in robert
pattinson's first outing as the caped
crusader since dano's casting was first
announced in october 2019 dano has
maintained the usual vow of silence
against spoilers but he's also been
willing to offer a few teases about his
unique take on the character in a recent
interview with empire magazine dano
called his costume intense and powerful
if you recognize dano that's because
he's been a working actor since the late
1990s in fact daniel's relationship with
warner brothers goes all the way back to
his first on-screen appearance in a 1998
episode of smart guy in the early years
of his career dano established himself
with a handful of small rules including
two minor appearances on the sopranos
while dano has worked on a few
television series including an emmy
nominated role on showtime's escape at
dannemora the majority of the actors
work has been on the big screen many
audiences first became aware of dano for
his role in 2006's little miss sunshine
but his portrayal of paul and eli sunday
in 2007's there will be blood may have
been what rocketed the young actor to
the a-list for his work in the film dana
was nominated for a bafta award for best
supporting actor in the years since
daniel has also appeared in movies as
varied as prisoners love and mercy and
swiss army men you can get a full look
at daniel's riddler when the batman hits
theaters on march 4th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]